[Music]
what have you guys learned about how to
make things work because you seem so
happy
post paradise we've had so many
conversations about real life
and what we were gonna do that I think
we just stayed on the same page about
everything I think more it's a
communication B it's it's giving
probably as much as you receive and the
fact that we have flexibility in our
jobs to take a weekend off to see each
other or travel to someplace that we
have the ability to do allows the
relationship to say sustained and keep
it moving forward I think that's
specially so are you moving moving it
out
yeah I'm considering it there's some
moving pieces with my business that I
have to figure out but I'm open to
expanding you know you're friends with
Rachel Rachel actually said in
interviews she never wanted any of her
girls like her girlfriends to date any
of her guys have you guys talked about
the timing here's a fun fact that I
asked Rachel before mérida she was like
don't mess my top three I said okay I
can say that I'm your girl that's like
um but I said who from your season would
I click with and she said Adam swear he
is she said Adams and she was so right
we saw Derek proposed to Taylor tonight
I gotta ask you guys put you on the spot
which you're gonna get a lot of have you
talked about marriage I'll let you take
that
no we are discussions and where are our
relationship is right now is we've
talked about where it is now and where
we take it day by day I think we live in
today but we plan for prepare for
tomorrow and as far as an engagement
it's something that we've talked about